guys I think Dana White of the USC might
be the greatest promoter ever
interesting I thought it was Don King
what happened it just got it out today
and I just saw the UFC post this or
someone else posted an Instagram but it
looks like it's legit pretty sure it
came from the UFC where Dana White says
that there because right now they're
continuing to put on the fights with no
fans right oh right
which is great because obviously it's
nice that they're fans there but at the
same time I want something to do on a
[ __ ] Saturday yeah I've watched all
of ozark in a week I am family UFC
experience from what I know who cares
let's go you know what I mean pump in
some crowd volume or something you can
figure it out but Dana White is the
greatest promote in UFC history because
I saw him or on this picture of him
quote saying they're looking to secure
an island to do all the fights so I
guess what they what to is rent out I'm
assuming rent out the island maybe
create a facility on the island I'm not
exactly sure how they're gonna work this
out but what a genius way control
everybody and everybody out brilliant
shitty thing is what happens if you have
Island electricity Island Wi-Fi island
hospitals Island [ __ ] isn't America [ __ ]
Ivan hospitals is the one issue that's
the one that I'm like have you ever been
to an island with electricity and Wi-Fi
like they gotta push this out to the
world that sounds like a that's a yeah
cuz again these are pay-per-view yeah
yeah so what island are they gonna use
Branson's island I'm but that you got
Heller Wi-Fi son baby the Virgin Islands
that's just gonna be a fire festival it
might beat it might be fire fest but
it's just it might be far fest
but would fire fest be bad if 20 people
showed up like this integrity that many
people no no I don't think you mean no I
think your fire fest in terms of people
showing up yeah I think it just it's
gonna calamity nothing's gonna work with
the infrastructure have been at bad if
it's not trying to support thousands of
people it's just trying to support 50 or
whatever right
yeah yeah I think I might hold up better
you know I like what he's trying to say
is this not gonna be successful
it wasn't literally sad but yeah I just
think it's a genius idea and right now
you have the opportunity I mean I don't
see any like boxing promoters trying to
put on fights I don't see any boxing
promoters doing anything to be honest
he's continuing to put on fights UFC if
it's not already the number one fights
for in the world it will come out of
this as the number one fly sport because
we're sitting around Saturday with
nothing to do we can't go out to the
movies we can't go to a show we can't go
to a bar you're gonna give us some live
entertainment on a Saturday we've had
live entertainment the people who are
willing geeks that people were willing
to say hey let's go I think WWE's
probably wack without an audience
yeah the people were willing to be like
yo who gives a [ __ ] the NFL hey we're
still having free agency yeah don't you
think it looks bad people are signing a
hundred dollar contract no we're still
gonna have we're still having the draft
yeah virtually who cares people are
dying for anything yeah people were
giving you anything as heartless as it
is they're gonna win yeah yeah man it's
just impressive dude I'm like good for
you and then khabib is not gonna be
fighting don't know if you saw this no
but like so kabhi was supposed to fight
Tony Ferguson I think this is a record
like fifth time that the fight has
gotten cancelled something crazy right
and because could be can't leave Russia
now everything's negotiable in Russia
okay fair enough literally everything
very negotiable in Russian yeah why can
he leave though he's saying he can't
leave because of corona and everybody's
on a lock team down as quarantine it's
like this is Russia be like you could
leave for $100,000 I guarantee that's
all it would take to get you out of the
car do you think he's ducking the fight
though no he's not ducking it I actually
think khabib is like a good guy like
he's actually like a truly good guy yeah
and he has like a moral compass that's
very strong
yeah honors big what this dude that's
why yeah [ __ ] outta McGregor is an honor
yeah I mean I think he would have beat
the [ __ ] out of him regardless
yeah no no but like that's amazing
personal yeah yeah 1% and so yeah so I
think it like I think the way he looks
at it and this is my assumption is he's
like look they're saying we shouldn't
travel
they're saying we shouldn't go outside
who the [ __ ] am I to break the rules I'm
no different than these other people
he's actually being really humble and
not want to do it he's a good guy yeah
but be a bad guy I'm [ __ ] bored
April 18th I want you to do I want you
have a nice fight with Tony Ferguson I
want to see some blood guts and mayhem
and that's gonna be perfect for me
that's how we're gonna have a nice
little bit of distraction
we need live events are they postponing
like two months do they have like a date
scheduled
no Justin gate she is another fighter
he's gonna step in on super late notice
maybe he was training for another fight
a lot of times these guys are always
like in shape yeah but um so Justin
gates she has the hardest name to [ __ ]
pronounce it's ji-ae th je gate key I'm
not gay key gate she is E's like a real
American boy so he's I guess pronounces
it that way probably French or some [ __ ]
but yeah dude it is um
he's gonna step in and fight Tony
Ferguson and I'll be honest with you I
think Ferguson as good as he is he's got
a lot to worry about because Ferguson
does get tagged mm-hmm like he does get
hit yeah
while he's you know very skilled he's
got amazing jujitsu he's got a really
weird style he gets touched yeah
and gate she's the guy who if he touches
you you're out but he's he slow
why is he oh he's fast he's a really
good fighter wait does he have a
weakness how does he not he gives the
best to okay so it's like if you have
power he's the type of guy who's gonna
they call him the most violent man and
MMA or he's coming straight at you yeah
he's swinging as hard as he can and if
you connect you're going down but what
happens when you come straight at
someone as soon as hard as you can
expose yourself 100% and you get got and
then you get got and so like in boxing
terms this would be the ideal metaphor
like a Floyd like I'm so good at defense
I just keep tagging you up yes now Tony
right as far as I'm concerned I've just
watched like highlights of his fights of
that kind of stuff he's an action
fighter as well he likes to move forward
so they're gonna move forward a D train
which I think benefits gay Chi if Tony
was like yeah kind of moving is shaken
like if Tony was like a style bender if
you will yeah right like style better
loves a fighter
stop that it would never fight gates
again there's two different but like if
a gate she like fighter just came at
Salva it's not on her pics he's a
counter punches a counter puncher need
to punch her exactly right right great
Trey so we'll see what happens I'm gonna
watch it I'm just excited there's gonna
be a fight there's a bunch of other good
fights on it like okay Dana White you're
durn do your thing you're supposed to
put on the fight you're supposed to
produce the fight that's your [ __ ]
job now you ought to earn your money
it's easy to put on a fight when
everybody can go I don't go that's where
the fight is I don't know I don't
usually watch fight sports I'll watch
Floyd fights yeah I might order this
[ __ ] fight so there's a
question there's nothing else some say
it's the only thing happening
[Applause]